if
hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others
I see there are a whole bunch of
questions
saved up here let's see there's one from
John here
is there a way to digitize DNA sequences
and examine them
so
we humans in every cell in our body we
have maybe a hundred trillion cells or
something every cell there's DNA
molecule that's all curled up and the
DNA molecule contains a sequence of
different units different collections of
atoms that correspond to different
so-called base pairs and all together
our DNA is divided into 23 chromosomes
well 23 times two chromosomes but
alsogether we have about six billion of
these base pairs and if we took all of
our DNA and and just sort of stretched
it out just the single molecule
stretched out and end it will be about a
meter long but that would be kind of a
meter long but only a few atoms thick so
to speak so the question is can we tell
what that sequence of base pairs on our
DNA actually is and so that there are
four four possible bases uh usually
written as a T C and G and
um
the uh everything about the way that
we're constructed
um is specified by those six billion
base pairs that specifies how every
protein in our body gets made and uh how
we eventually sort of get put together
so the question is can we how do we how
do we find that sequence of six billion
base pairs
um that represent us
and I don't know somebody like me is a
practical matter well as a practical
matter it became possible to kind of
um
uh read that sequence of base pairs in
the early 2000s uh to sequence this
whole Human Genome and it became sort of
a thing one could do uh around 2010 I
think and I was in the very first sort
of cohort of people who uh uh said okay
let me get my genome sequenced and it
arrived back on a on a a disk drive
basically
um you give a blood sample it could be a
sample of any cells in your body pretty
much
um any any cells that still have their
cell nucleus with the DNA and so on in
it so avoid the red blood cells but any
other like a white blood cell will do
fine or or any other uh thing that you
get from you know spitting in a tube or
something you'll you'll have cells that
fall off the uh the side of your cheek
into into saliva and so on and that's
enough to um you just have to have a
cell with um uh with its DNA still
inside it and then then from that DNA
you're you're finding the sequence and
the sequence is then what sort of
specifies how how one works someone can
then go and sort of uh explore that that
DNA sequence and find out things about
oneself like it was fairly easy to
determined yes I should have brown eyes
which you could just look at them look
visually and you'll see yes that's
really true but that's something that's
fairly easy to tell from DNA more
difficult to tell are all sorts of other
kind of traits and all sorts of other
kind of health related sorts of things
but the question that was asked here is
how do you actually find that sequence
of bass pairs from the DNA and
well there are a number of technologies
that exist for doing that
um but let me explain the the big point
big point is you've got this all these
six billion based pairs
um the there are various Technologies
where people imagine like laying out the
whole DNA and just in a very powerful
microscope just looking at what each of
the base pairs is that hasn't worked out
so far what instead tends to be done is
you take that that big sequence of DNA
and you break it into pieces you break
it into pieces that maybe 30 maybe 100
base pairs long they're just a lot of
fragments then it turns out there are
technologies that allow you to figure
out what the sequence of base pairs on
each fragment is so you have this big
bucket of uh you know a um what is it a
billion or so
um examples of this is what this 30 base
pair sequence
um of uh
um
fragment of DNA this is its sequence you
know a t g c c g t t a whatever it is
um that's its sequence for all these all
these length 30 fragments and the way
one sets it up is one has a chemical and
enzyme that uh basically breaks the DNA
up
randomly into these fragments so you've
got all these different fragments you
managed to find the sequence for every
fragment you might have a billion
different fragments with each with a
different sequence now the question is
so you've got all these fragments you
know all these fragments came from
somewhere on the original DNA I should
explain another point when you get the
original piece of DNA from that original
cell
at the beginning you just have one copy
of it but there's a neat trick
um called uh
um
RNA polymerase there's a there's a neat
trick or PCR polymerized Chain Reaction
um there's a neat trick that allows you
to uh to amplify that DNA and so what
what started is just one copy you can
end up getting sort of a huge number of
copies and it's from those separate
copies that you when you when you smash
them into their length 30 sequences
you're smashing different copies into
those length 30 sequences and what
you've got is essentially these these
places where for all practical purposes
it was a random length 30 sequence that
you snipped out of this length 6 billion
altogether sequence of DNA so you've got
let's say a billion of these length 30
sequences all floating around each of
those billion you know what its sequence
was so now you have to reassemble things
because you know that in the end each of
those sequences came from somewhere on
the 6 billion base pair original whole
sequence so it's kind of a a um a puzzle
thing that you have to align all those
sequences so for example you might find
one sequence that has a particular
ending to it you might go a t t c g a
and then you find another sequence which
has ATT CGA I think it's what I said
which happens to show up at the
beginning of that sequence so then you
you get the idea those two sequences
must follow from each other and so you
start being able to assemble the whole
the whole uh the whole DNA sequence from
these different pieces this technique is
usually called shotgun sequencing where
you sort of smash the thing apart and
then you have to do this reassembly and
one of the bigger problems when this was
originally done was that it took a lot
of computer effort to figure out uh what
a roller you you might have had to just
sort of match every one of those billion
fragments with every other one of those
billion fragments and that would be very
complicated but there are better ways to
do it so that you can sort of align
things so that you can then reconstruct
the original sequence from all those
fragments of the sequence
so typically these uh the thing that is
that's out of the length 30 let's say uh
block is uh you talk about that as a
read there's a single sort of read where
you get uh 30 base pairs read out from
that fragment and then the idea is you
you try and figure out you know how
would these fragments go together and
you'll end up with a certain depth
because you will have said well I've got
one assembly one sequence that one
solution to how these things could have
gone together here but another solution
another solution another solution so a
pretty common thing early on it's it's
gotten bigger now is that it will be 30
deep length 30 reads which means each
each sequence is um
each each fragment is a length 30 that's
the length of the read and then the
depth is the number of different
reconstructions that you've made why do
you make multiple reconstructions well
because all kinds of things go wrong
when you do these reads they're not
perfectly accurate sometimes you know an
a will be misread as a c or something
like this and so what you then do is you
say well I've got this these 30
possibilities for what occurs at a
particular position on my genome and
that uh
that and so what you then do is to say
okay most of these are T's all right
that's probably really a t oh you know I
can't really tell it might be a t or it
might be an a that's maybe uncertain at
that position
um and so when you look at a genome that
usually there's there's different kind
of letters that are used to encode
um what what possible value there is at
that particular position so it might
just be it's a t or it might say I think
it's n which means one has no idea what
that particular uh what that base pair
at that position is or it might be
something else which means it's either a
t or an A
and so that's the thing you're trying to
put together is you make what is called
the consensus sequence which is the one
which comes from sort of typically the
the largest number of possible largest
number of uh if it said it was a t but
that was the most likely thing it said
it was then the consensus sequence will
be one where you have say it's a t at
that position now it's kind of tricky
when you specify a genome sequence
because everybody has
uh okay so there is a sort of standard
sequence which is kind of well there
isn't a standard human sequence because
we're all different
um but there is a uh you might imagine
doesn't really true that the sort of an
average human genome sequence uh not
really clear what that means because you
know there's eight billion humans right
now and uh you know what's really the
average there isn't really and a good
average when this was originally done uh
the main person who invented shotgun
sequencing actually a large part of his
DNA was the standard human sequence so
to speak but if you if you um uh if you
say for each given person they differ
from the standard sequence the so-called
reference sequence at any given time
there's usually a reference human genome
I think we're on
I don't know if it's still build 37 of
the reference human genome I'm not sure
every every so often there's sort of an
update to what the reference human
genome is but what you do when you talk
about your particular genome is you'll
say well for example how does my genome
differ from the reference human genome
the most common difference is a single
nucleotide polymorphism a snip an SNP
which is a place where there was a t in
the reference sequence but you had a g
there for example and so you'll you'll
note that there was a a particular
snippet particular change and we all
have uh what is it
some number of millions tens of millions
of of snips relative to the reference
human genome we're all we all differ
from the reference by by lots of single
point changes
there are not just single point changes
there also sometimes whole sections of
DNA that are missing in a particular
person or additions to a particular
piece of DNA well sometimes there are
pieces of DNA that will be a rep that
well there'll be multiple repeats in one
person and only one repeat in other
people
one feature of these cases where things
are missing or where things repeat or
where there's an extra base pair added
is it means that if you try and line up
sequences if you try and line up your
sequence to the reference sequence you
don't get to say at positions such and
such on chromosome the DNA has broken up
into these a particular person's DNA is
broken up into these into these 23
chromosomes
um but the the just that's just pieces
of DNA that are separately uh exist in
cells but but uh on you know chromosome
one we might say position five million
742 or something what do you have there
is it a t or a c
um well that isn't completely meaningful
because uh the any given person might
have had additions deletions and so on
ahead of that five millionth position so
their five million won't align with the
5 million of the reference sequence so
it's a tricky business to try and say
you know what to try and label oh it's
this snip that is at this quote's
position and that means that every snip
typically gets an ID number it's usually
RS and then some series of digits that
represent that particular snip and one
knows on the reference genome one word
knows where that snip is in your
particular genome it might have moved
around relative to where it was in terms
of coordinate position relative to the
reference human genome and and typically
the way one deals with that uh I don't
know whenever I go look at my genome
which is fun to do from time to time
when you see some some uh brand new
piece of research that says if you have
this snip then it means your you're
going to have this trait or whatever
else uh how does one actually find
something in one's genome I I use the
evil language we have a nice way of
representing genomes and um uh
essentially what I do is I always say
well let's look at the reference human
genome let's look at the flanking
sequence around that particular uh that
particular position so let's say around
that particular position things always
go atcg
gtca 80 whatever on one side and then
some other sequence on the other side
well as soon as I've got enough base
pairs in that that I know go on either
side I can basically just search for
those flanking sequences in my whole
genome and the chances are the only
place where those flanking sequences
will occur is right around this position
that I'm looking for with the snippet
wires so that's a that's a convenient
way to kind of align oneself with a
particular position on the genome and by
the way that kind of mechanism of
looking for sequences like that
um the uh the immune system makes use of
that lots of things make use of this
idea of and the immune system one breaks
pieces of viral genome for example into
I think they're length 12 sequences
something like that and one's using the
fact that if you've got this length 12
sequence you can kind of tell is it part
of me or is it not part of me because in
a length 12 sequence there are 4 to the
12 possible
um uh possible sequences that the made a
base pads that are length 12 and you can
kind of say well of those only a very
small number will be actually present in
my 6 billion base pairs in my genome and
so you can use that in the immune system
uses that in a very fundamental way as
its way of detecting is it is it
something that came from your genome
that's part of you or is it some alien
thing that came from a virus or a
bacterium or something else that's an
alien thing not that is has a has a
sequence that fragment of the sequence
has never been seen before
so
in any case the the um sort of the
zooming out a bit the the main thing
one's doing is you've got this DNA you
want to figure out what the base pest
sequence is you break the DNA into these
little sections you read each section
then you align the results you get from
all those sections to be able to make
this whole long continuous 6 billion
base per thing
um and then you uh
um and then I'm sort of describing how
you make use of what you get from that
uh I will say that the Technologies for
uh reading for making those length 30
reads there are several Technologies
there
um and uh some of them involved that
they basically involve sequentially
going down those those uh those little
fragments of DNA and and sort of uh
watching One bass pair at a time
um what what happens in some common core
action I think there's the main
technology I think uses glass beads with
different kinds of um materials on those
glass beads that um uh basically as the
as you sort of uh walking down this
piece of DNA you see different signals
depending on whether the thing that came
next was a was a c or a g or whatever
else
um there's a um a nanopore mechanism
where you're kind of pulling the DNA
through a membrane and you're sort of
watching what happens as each different
bass pair kind of goes through the
membrane there was some very direct
techniques that people try to develop
one of the ones that was quite fun was
to literally lay the DNA out on in some
kind of plastic
container and literally look at this DNA
that's been laid out through an electron
microscope to see what the base per
sequence was actually like that that
technology never came to fruition at
least not yet but that's a type of thing
one one can imagine and in general you
know a sequencing machine I don't think
I've seen a sequencing machine in a few
years but last time I saw them they were
you know in in a bio lab there's a
certain tendency for everything to look
like a kitchen appliance
um and you know sequencing machines kind
of like you put the DNA in and it's this
thing it's this box and and they're
different technologies that allow you to
sequence more quickly
um and uh but not quite as accurately or
sequence accurately and it takes hours
or even days I think to get sequences
out and then the amount of data you get
from the sequence is quite long if
you've just got the consensus sequence
then uh that that's just six billion
base pairs but if you've also got every
every different uh read then that's much
more data I think nowadays I think the
um I think I just had a bunch of I just
because I like these things I I get my
genome sequenced every so often with
with ever better technology and I think
nowadays it is length hundred reads and
I think they're like a hundred deep
reads so there's a hundred copies of
each of each each thing that's read I
think
um I will say that there are places
where all kinds of things there are all
kinds of funky issues like for example
whenever there's repeats in the DNA
sequence those are hard to deal with
with the shotgun sequencing technique
because once you have enough repeats if
it just goes 8080
et cetera et cetera et cetera you kind
of don't know how to align things
there's no way to know when you've got
all those ATA T Etc together it's like
how long was that piece and how did this
at 8080 align with that same uh that
same repetition in some other fragment
and and so that causes trouble and
sometimes when there are genes genes are
the the pieces of DNA that will make
single proteins so there'll be some run
of of parts of the of your genome that
are uh uh what are used to make a
particular protein so you're you're in
the end it's transcribed onto RNA then
the ribosome that kind of walks down the
RNA strand extruding pieces of of
protein
um it it knows to kind of start reading
at a particular place on the DNA there's
a so-called start code on there and it
keeps going until it gets to the stop
codon and then it stops and that's the
end of that's the end of producing that
particular protein
um but uh sometimes there are Gene where
in the history of biological evolution
those genes were very similar and so
while they might have ended up in
different places on your genome they're
very similar and that causes all kinds
of confusion for this shotgun sequencing
technique because it's like there are
two parts that really look the same but
they're actually from different pieces
of the genome because those two genes
had some kind of biological evolution uh
convergence so to speak
another thing that happens is the the
ends of DNA are these things called
telomeres and telomeres are repeating
blocks usually if you're kind of um in
if your genome is in great shape you'll
have about 50 telomeres at each end and
they kind of hold the the end caps of
the DNA
um as as DNA replicates or you get older
uh presumably there are fewer telomeres
um uh and although that's been sort of a
an issue of you know do you just lose
telomeres as you as as the more
replications of your DNA and as you get
older and that's certain then your DNA
sort of unspools and that's bad news
um or can you you know eat well uh you
know be healthy and actually there's a
thing called telomerase and enzyme which
adds telomeres and can you actually just
you know keep keep the telomeres at
reasonable length
um but in any case that one feature of
these telomeres is that because they're
repeating blocks they really can't be
very well well read by this kind of
shotgun technique and so sort of if you
want to know how many telomeres do you
have left at each end of your of your
genome that's sort of a separate thing
that you have to work out differently
from the main sequencing process
so anyway that was a little bit on on
how uh DNA gets some
uh how to sequence DNA how to find the
sequence of base pairs corresponding to
uh your particular genome sequence
let's see
um
uh okay
let's see there's a
there's a question here from Philip
about is a complete family tree of
humanity
a realistic possibility
so you know there's eight billion humans
right now give or take about 100 billion
humans probably have lived in the
history of our species
um I think that to reconstruct what the
family tree of all of those humans is
seems like a realistic possibility
uh the you know there are some places
like I think famously Iceland which was
settled in what a thousand A.D or
something
um where pretty much the complete
uh
genealogical history of of the of the
population there is known and and that
was done at some point I don't know when
was it it was about
15 years ago maybe there was a big
effort to do you don't need to sequence
everybody if you know enough about kind
of the the birth records and so on you
can you can just sequence particular
people and then
that you can kind of deduce what the
intermediate people must have been and
occasionally you find all sorts of uh
strange things where you know this
sequence couldn't possibly go with this
person being a a uh you know a sibling
of this person so something was wrong
with the with the birth records and so
on
um but I think that it becomes perfectly
possible and I think it will be you know
it will gradually be doable to really
fill in the uh the sort of pretty much
complete genealogical tree of our
species now some aspects of that are
pretty well known already
um there are
um you can deduce things about sort of
where did your ancestors come from in
the world
um and they're a so-called haplogroups
which are kind of a way to characterize
uh sequences in the DNA to say oh these
folks came from uh you know they were
indigenous people in in somewhere in the
air Americas or these people were from
you know southern Europe or or or
whatever some amount of time in the past
why does that work well so
uh okay so there are usually there are
two pieces that one looks at so the
mitochondrion which is the energy source
for cells but it's a piece of our cells
that replicates independently of the
main cell and it has its own DNA so
mitochondrial DNA is passed down the
maternal line it's passed from mother to
child and so on and uh the um and so for
for the US males of the species our
mitochondria are kind of um you know
it's the end of the line so to speak we
don't we don't pass our mitochondria to
our to our progeny
um but um uh so if you follow the
mitochondria you're following the female
line of um uh uh of a particular
um uh genealogical line so to speak
um and then for males of the species the
Y chromosome and the the uh the X and Y
chromosomes you know females of the
species have two X chromosomes males of
the species have an X and A Y chromosome
that's a that's a particular human
feature if you look at other organisms
you'll find different different
Arrangements of chromosomes and
different things that lead to lead to
kind of the
um
different male female Etc uh
configurations to different species but
but that's what we humans have and so if
you look at why chromosomes those are
passed from you know from father to to
son so to speak and that's a different a
different line but so when you look at
mitochondrial DNA for example you're
you're able to sort of see back down the
female line so to speak uh what with the
origins well what is why does that work
it works because when you
where each generation
there are small changes in the DNA more
or less you get sort of half your DNA is
from your parent from one parent half
your DNA is from your other parent and
if you look at a particular chromosome
um in the DNA what you'll see is that
there'll be a run of stuff that comes
from one parent and then a run of stuff
that comes from another parent and so on
I think they're usually about so I don't
know half a dozen maybe a dozen
crossovers on a single on a single
chromosome so you'll have a big run of
uh you know uh sort of father
produce DNA a big run of mother produced
DNA and so on
um that isn't that that means there are
sort of traits that tend to be in common
from one parent but it's very hard to
see that because the on on the it's kind
of like
the functionality of the DNA the the
what the what genes produce what
proteins and so on it's all been kind of
jumbled up in terms of the sequence so
the you know the gene that encodes
things to do with I don't know eye color
we write next to the gene that encodes
something to do with you know cells in
your kidney or something like this and
there's no it's not like oh this section
it's not a well organized thing where
it's like oh this section involves the
brain this section involves the foot
things like this it's all jumbled up
but in any case the the point is that as
you go from
uh from half your DNA is from one parent
half your DNA is from another parent but
there's also every time DNA replicates
there's a certain rate of making
mistakes there's a certain rate of where
it should have been a t it ends up being
a c for example and we all have about I
think it's about 700
000 uh Snips 700 000 places where one
mistake was made relative to uh either
of our parents so to speak so we have
about that number of sort of um uh never
seen before
um changes to our DNA and those never
seen before changes are important they
might be really good they might be what
makes you unique and great or whatever
or they might be something that causes
trouble
um but any case they're things which are
changes and if you look over the course
of many generations you'll see those
changes progressively building up so
you'll go from something where all the
DNA is just like it was for this this
ancestor and and it progressively
changes and that allows you to kind of
figure out sort of things like how many
generations was it from this original
DNA back here to the DNA that we now
have today but it also means that
because those changes seven hundred
thousand is pretty small compared to 6
billion or 3 billion from each parent
um the uh
um it's uh
it means that you can pretty well Trace
sort of what the parentage was
um even independent of those those
changes that are getting made and so
that means that you can trace back uh
kind of where uh you you can see sort of
what what was the DNA of the ancestors
and then what people have done is to try
and compare the uh uh for particular DNA
they ask sort of where were the folks
who had that DNA where did they live in
the world and so you get these maps of
where uh you know your DNA where did it
originate in the world and you can also
see in the course of sort of uh the
evolution of the species you know who
mated with who to mix in DNA from this
place and that place and so on I mean
most of human history most kind of
mating was pretty local
um I mean it's only in fairly recent
times that it's like uh uh you know
they'll be there'll be children whose
parents come from vastly different parts
of the world
um but uh and so
then that allows one to deduce oh you
know with my DNA I can tell my ancestors
came from this particular part of the
world and there's been quite a bit of
work that's been done on tracking sort
of migrations of large populations back
in the past and you can say well you
know 20 000 years ago my ancestors hung
out in this part of the world
etc etc etc and and that's that's
something that is um at this point a
pretty well developed uh technology now
occasionally it'll be like well you're
you know come from this part of the
world but there's one percent that some
utterly exotic thing from some
completely different corner of the world
that's usually a mistake that's usually
because there was some change in the DNA
and the algorithm that was used to
decide which of the different possible
places where your DNA might come from
was it from didn't take account of that
uh sort of unusual change and so it said
well you're or you know one percent some
completely weird place that you can't
imagine uh you know any of your
ancestors ever had anything to do with
um so
the uh uh let's see so I mean that
that's that's one part of the kind of
genealogy of of our species that's at
this point fairly well known as these
these kind of large-scale uh kind of
groupings in these haplotypes and so on
um and uh uh then you know in terms of
really being able to fill in the finer
details of sort of the complete net of
uh uh of of the genealogy of our species
I'm sure that will become possible
um and I think it will be uh it'll be
kind of amusing you can I mean you know
there's a lot of uh well for example
they're a particular uh I don't know
Genghis Khan for example from what the
1200s 1300s
um uh you know had an awful lot of
children and so there's an awful lot of
people who have some sort of piece of of
you know Genghis Khan deduce you know
derive DNA I think there's also uh I
think somewhere in Ireland I think
there's another one of these um very
prolific sources of DNA
um but uh these are
there are things like this
um but I think it will be possible to
undoubtedly to sort of reproduce the
whole net
um of connections there
let's see
uh
let's see so one
it's a question here from prabh is DNA a
tree or semilattis well
um so
you know when there's a piece of DNA
and
you're passing it from parent to child
the DNA that the child gets is slightly
slightly different from the parent as I
mentioned
now it's always possible that sort of
somewhere down the line you know this
the the children of the children of the
children on this side will end up having
the exact same DNA as the children of
the children children on the side but
it's unbelievably unlikely
um I think there's a there's a fun movie
that has some science fiction kind of
concept that
um uh that there'll be kind of a a
galactic monarchy or something where the
next Monarch has chosen
um based on them having happening to
have the exact same DNA as as the
previous one so to speak I think one
will be waiting a very long time for the
next Monarch and that um in that
scenario if one was doing it with with
the full structure of DNA so the chance
that there's sort of a convergence
um is uh sort of a chance convergence of
a large chunk of DNA is really low
um the chance that uh so what tends to
happen is these Snips that I mentioned
um for various reasons uh which I'm not
sure whether they're completely known
there are some places that are kind of
more likely to have errors of Errors of
transcription errors of transmission of
the Next Generation than others there
are places that are more likely to have
uh sort of changes than others
um and there's some evidence that there
are in particularly in lower organisms
maybe viruses things like that that
there are sort of it's in the interest
of the organism to evolve to change to
adapt to the environment and sometimes
environmental factors and sort of stress
from the environment changing will cause
the DNA to tend to evolve more quickly
for there to be more errors of of
transcription and so on because it's
sort of in the interest of the organism
to seek out different forms so to speak
um because you know the environment has
changed and you've got to adapt and if
you just stay the same as you were
before that's not a good good strategy
so I think
um but but the idea that there would be
sort of major convergence of different
DNA from different branches of of the
tree is is very unlikely now having said
that
when it comes to if you look at the tree
of life and you ask you know are there
mechanisms but the first thing to
realize about the tree of life you know
the the sequence of organisms going back
whatever three billion years or
something
um to the very first living uh organisms
on Earth
um the uh one of the things that's
always utterly shocking about the tree
of life and about
um uh the things that we have as we say
well we've got this mechanism we've got
this thing about how brains work and
it's this particular Protein that's used
in brains or it's this particular
mechanism of how sleep works or whatever
else it is and then you ask yourself how
long has it been like that and you
realize well actually it's been like
that for 500 million years the first
time that particular mechanism existed
was really long ago and you know we
might say uh we are sort of these
wonderful I don't know what to know a
few hundred thousand year old species
and and uh um
it's uh you know we should be very
impressed with the attributes we have
but an awful lot of the mechanisms that
operate biologically for us are
extremely old
um in in terms of of biological history
now you know one of the things that
happens is there are things that get
invented like I don't know eyes get
invented things that detect light uh
other things you know walking gets
invented
um well some of those things they've
been invented more than once in the tree
of life like eyes I think have invented
maybe four times
and you can see that they've been
independently invented because the
detailed engineering solutions that have
been adopted by different organisms are
completely different and and you
wouldn't expect you know and you can't
find sort of a fossil record that takes
you from here to there so there is this
phenomenon of convergent evolution where
some mechanism like eyes gets to arise
because well it was a good thing to do
if you were a critter living on the
ocean floor it was a good thing to do if
you were a flying Critter you needed
eyes in both cases but they weren't sort
of connected
um in in the tree of life they didn't
one didn't evolve from the other they
independently discovered the same
mechanism so that can happen but if you
ask what are the gene what are the
genetic aspects of um of how those
things were constructed they'll be
completely different it's like two
programs that do the two computer
programs that do pretty much the same
thing but they were working by different
programmers and they work in completely
different ways
um now uh
yeah so I mean there are mechanisms uh
that will be in common because they're
sort of lower level mechanisms like
there's a mechanism when a biological
organism grows
um there's a mechanism by which
different types of tissue can be you can
differentiate into different types of
tissue you can end up with you know
something as bone something is muscle
whatever else
um and that's a uh that differentiation
process is governed by an incredibly
ancient mechanism that's existed for I
don't know what at least a billion years
more than that probably and and that
mechanism will be in common between the
Critter that discovered eyes that work
this way and the Critter that discovered
eyes that work that way
let's see
there's a question here How likely is it
that genetic engineering can create
mammalian species with superhuman
intelligence
um
the
so one question is
if we look at
uh well if you look at biological
evolution
what mostly is happening is the critters
that
are more successful in the environment
tend to have more kids and so whatever
traits they have
um they get passed to more organisms for
their kids and then that keeps going and
it's a it's a pretty surprisingly quick
process sort of mathematically that if
there's a small Advantage you know if if
this trait causes you to have a few more
kids than this other trait the trait
that causes you to have more kids will
win out in the population because
they'll just be more and more and more
organisms that have passed that genetics
down to their to their uh progeny and so
that will that will tend to take over
and so
but that process kind of only works well
it depends on what you mean by the
environment whatever the environment is
you know if it turns out that you know
folks who get more education have less
kids or something then that will cause
it to be the case that that will be uh
you know disfavored in the in the
population in the end but you know in in
um and in modern times some of the
traits that would be like oh if you have
that medical condition you're not going
to make it to the point where you have
kids for example well with modern
medicine you will make it and so that
trait that would have been something
that would have died out in the
population no longer dies out because uh
fortunately uh you know medicine has
allowed people to live longer with that
trait and potentially pass that trait to
their kids
so
the thing so then a question might be
well what are some traits that might
arise in the population that would be
sort of more successful and that would
cause sort of you know traits where
people will have more kids if they have
this trait
um and uh uh that's an interesting
question whether there is evolution
still going on in the human population
that presumably still is it may be
rather bizarre because unlike other
times in biological history When the
evolution was you know can you get
enough food and can you pick the right
nut from the tree and whatever else it
is the the forces of evolution in
today's world are are very different and
are often you know have economic
characters and other kinds of things
that are very different from the ones
that have existed kind of in the wild so
to speak in the past although there are
presumably still forces and one can ask
you know what are traits that you can
see in the population today
that um uh that um have um
uh that are kind of uh that seem to be
better than you know a small percentage
trait that seems to be better than than
other people have so there's there's one
that I know uh that has to do with red
blood cells carriers of oxygen in the
blood and um it's a trait that um causes
uh some people to have a higher
concentration of red blood cells than
most of the population and actually this
trait was discovered because one of the
things that you know if you if you're an
athlete and you want to have more
endurance and so on you want more red
blood cells and you can get that by uh
uh by basically injecting erythropoietin
EPO it's a substance that causes the
production of red blood cells and you
know people have kind of outlawed you
know uh doping with that that substance
um as a way to kind of improve your
athletic performance because that's
thought to be not um you know not a fair
way to to be a a human competitor so to
speak but there was a particular
individual who who did really well in a
bunch of athletic competitions and
people were saying You must be you know
doping with the CPO thing and it turned
out no he wasn't actually he just had a
genetic modification that caused him to
produce more red blood cells than the
typical person and presumably having
more red blood cells is an advantage
there doesn't seem to be an obvious
downside to it it just seems like it
gives you more endurance and so on and
um that uh so that's an example of a
kind of a trait in the population that
um I don't think it necessarily leads to
uh you know more kids and therefore it's
not going to my natural selection it's
not going to sort of take over the
population but it's an interesting trait
if you have it so to speak
um well the
the thing that um uh
um uh so so the question then is well
all right let's say there are traits
where you say this is a good trait
um and uh now you start saying well
should we uh sort of engineer that trait
into uh kids of the Next Generation
very tricky issue I mean that's a very
tricky messy story because there are
cases where you say well gosh if there's
some nasty genetic disease that's
produced by some particular uh some
particular feature of DNA and you detect
that at the level of uh uh you know you
detect that in in for example a um uh
what would become you know fertilized
egg that's going to turn into a fetus
and so on if you can detect that you can
go and you can go and make modifications
to the DNA sequence and you can remove
that genetic defect surely you say
that's a good thing presumably yes
um because it will prevent that
otherwise that child would have this
nasty genetic disease might not even you
know survive to birth might have all
kinds of other problems and gosh we can
fix that we can just make uh do Gene
editing I should explain that something
was discovered about almost was it 10
years ago a little bit more than that
was the ability to essentially just edit
a piece of of DNA to go in to your DNA
it's a um uh uh I can explain some other
time how that works but basically what's
happening is you you send in this kind
of uh
um
um this kind of
molecule that essentially searches out
these flanking sequences I was talking
about these flanking sequence as a way
you know if one's trying to find a
particular snip in one's genome on a
computer you look for you know search
for atgc whatever else it is well Gene
editing does the same thing it it you
you give it these these um I guess the
primers
um these these sequences of of uh little
fragments of of DNA sequences and you
say okay when you see these two flanking
sequences go in and edit the stuff in
between them and change it from this to
that it's a very kind of uh it's kind of
almost like a search replace text
editing kind of operation it's it's very
similar to what you would see in like uh
well pattern matching and more from
language a bunch of other different
places
um where you see that same kind of you
know you see something which looks like
this make a change to the to to
something associated with that anyway
with Gene editing you can potentially
um make
um
uh make changes to um uh uh to DNA
um in uh you can you can edit things and
this was this was done once and
everybody got very upset about it
um and uh the um it's not clear
um
what uh it's not clear what should be
done how it should be done and so on one
of the things that tends to happen is
somebody says oh it's terrific let's
just make this change to uh DNA let's
let's change it so that everybody has
blue eyes let's say
um well might turn out that there's some
unintended consequence that if you do
that then you know that change in the
genome also has the effect that I don't
know people will tend to develop some
particular disease or some such other
thing it's hard to know right now what
we're doing is we're leaving it to fate
and nature and so on kind of rolling the
dice and saying whatever nature does
we'll be okay with that
um what one is asking about is whether
if we know sort of engineering wise if
we say well we think based on this
engineering calculation effectively that
this will produce a better result you
know we can engineer the better human so
to speak uh should we do that
and what is you know if we think we know
what's going on and can say this will be
the outcome is it worse to do it when we
think we know what's going on than when
we're just rolling the dice
unclear complicated story
um but in terms of the traits that lead
to intelligence
um whatever that means
um I mean that's a particularly
complicated mess because there are there
are surely you know first of all it's
very unclear what we mean by quotes
intelligence I mean there are there are
you know we we have um
um uh you know one of the things we
learn from computers is given any
computer you can program it to do
anything that any other computer can do
and I'm pretty sure it's the same thing
with brains given any brain you can
program it effectively to do what any
other brain can do it might not do it
quite as quickly it might have certain
other attributes but it's pretty much
you know sort of universal so to speak
um but then the question would be well
okay which which brain is faster at
doing which thing which brain does does
this has this or that trait and surely
there are differences there just as
there are differences in you know so the
heights of different people and and
other other characteristics but saying
you know generally people people have
this idea back in 100 years ago or so
now this notion of the the quotient of
general intelligence so to speak it's
not clear how meaningful that is because
it's not clear you know when you say
well I want to I want to use my brain to
do this particular thing well you might
be really great at doing that particular
thing but really crummy at doing this
other thing what does that mean for your
general intelligence quotient I don't
think the general really really survives
it becomes you know are you good at
doing these particular kinds of uh
visual IQ tests or something and that is
well you can measure that and some
people will be better at those than
others just as some people run faster
than others
um it's but that doesn't uh to then
conclude that there's a whole then the
real question is if you look at
different occupations and different
things people do in the world how
aligned are they with different kinds of
attributes that you can measure with
with different kinds of tests and so on
and the answer is it's really
complicated I mean when you look at oh I
don't know let's say doing mathematics
and a research type level one of the
things you notice there is you say well
if you're going to do mathematics or
research level you have to be good at
blah blah blah you might say you know
you have to be good at dealing with
numbers or something turns out it isn't
true it turns out there are a whole
bunch of very different ways to do
sophisticated research mathematics you
can be very good at thinking
geometrically you can be very good at
thinking kind of symbolically you can be
good at seeing patterns between this and
that there are different ways to do it
the end result is you do good math but
how you get there and the kinds of
explanations that you give to yourself
and other people may be utterly
different so to say well you know we
measure this particular one trait and
that's that's the thing that determines
that you're going to be good at math
it's not going to work that way it
doesn't work that way so
if you say you know are there changes
you can make in uh biological changes
that can lead to
um uh sort of changes in overall
intelligence it's unclear what that
means but there are surely things that
in principle you could measure them we
don't know what pretty much any of those
traits are genetically
um that where you could measure it and
say okay you know if you have more of
this uh if you if you're a gene for this
has this characteristic then you're more
likely to be able to do this kind of
puzzle quickly
now having said that things like that
tend to be really hard to figure out
from from genetics there are some traits
like eye color that are pretty
straightforward where you can just look
at individual little little regions or
individual Snips on the genome and you
can determine it but for example height
is one that people have looked at
extensively and it isn't something where
you just say there's a gene for height
you know if you have this variant with
ATC here then you'll be at least six
feet tall and if you have this variant
then you'll be less than five feet tall
you know there isn't any known such
thing and presumably what happens is
that there are a whole collection of
different genes hundreds maybe thousands
of genes that all contribute in some way
or another to to overall height there's
some evidence for that because if you
look at the distribution of human
Heights it follows a normal distribution
and that's a typical thing that you get
when you have many independent uh
variables that are all being averaged
together to to get to the final result
it's like there are many independent
variables that determine in one way or
another oh your your leg bone in this
way is going to be slightly longer oh
you're you know your your spine is going
to be slightly longer or shorter in this
way etc etc et cetera and that that will
be um uh the um
uh that that's a combination of all
those things that leads to height but so
I think the uh I I have to say if I were
going to sort of um uh say what's likely
to happen in practice in the um kind of
uh genetic um uh you know genetics of of
humans and intelligence and so on I have
to say tool use is a much better piece
of Leverage for improving the effective
intelligence of humans I suspect than
going in and and uh doing uh potentially
very crazy things with the genome I mean
it's much easier to say uh gosh you know
this type of thing that used to require
uh some particular intellectual trait to
be able to do it
um actually now we can just get a
computer to do that we don't have to
know how to do it in my own life uh you
know I got interested in doing physics
when I was a kid and I uh didn't like
doing some of the sort of mechanical
aspects of math that were involved and
so I started using computers to do that
and then I built a bunch of tools which
fortunately lots and lots of other
people have now had a chance to use two
um to do mathematical calculation with
computers and now at this point it's
like back in the day if I hadn't been
able to do certain kinds of algebraic
computations I would have been sort of
locked out of doing various kinds of
physics but as it was I got computers to
do those things and in fact they did
them a lot better than people could do
them and so I was not locked out I was
kind of pulled in to doing a lot of
things that um uh that weren't really
easy for other people to do because I
was using computer so it's kind of like
instead of trying to improve yourself
improve the tools you use use the tools
and um uh that's that's sort of the the
the faster way ahead so to speak then oh
let's change the genome and see what
happens so to speak plus you don't have
to grow from uh you know you don't have
to biologically grow to make use of
tools you just have to choose to do it I
suppose that would be a Pitch for my
life work of building our computational
language as sort of a a general tool to
let people do
do with computers that sort of extend
the things that they think about by
using computers and I think that's a
that's a more sure path to sort of
effective enhanced intelligence for
humans than anything that has to do with
with uh messing with the uh with the
genome I mean that the history of trying
to do things like that is fairly
terrible uh I mean in in um uh you know
at various times people have said oh
there's this collection of people that
have this great trait that have whatever
this is you know in in history this has
tended to end very badly
um with a lot of a lot of bad things
happening and um you know there's
there's at this point uh I think not a
lot of enthusiasm uh for uh kind of this
kind of genetic um uh you know genetic
selection or genetic editing or whatever
else but it's a tricky thing because in
a case where uh you can say this this is
a person who's going to die at you know
at a young age unless you make this
genetic change it's kind of like you
might say well you should make that
genetic change and there's a good
argument for that but I think there's
perhaps a uh it becomes more complicated
when that change will get propagated to
Future Generations which which it will
typically so this is a
um uh this is this is a tricky tricky
business
um
let's see
uh
there's a question from Zayden about
epic genetics
oh let's see I want to get into that
um
boy we've really had a a genomics day
today
um
okay let's talk a little bit about that
so
one of the issues is
you have a genome and
that
specifies kind of what proteins you'll
make which specifies sort of what what
you as an organism how you as an
organism are constructed but there are
there are other factors there are other
things about for example your
environment that can affect aspects of
how
um
uh sort of how much of a particular
protein is made whether that protein is
made whether there are modifications of
that protein afterwards whether there
are even modifications to your DNA not
to the base pair sequence but there's
this process of methylation which is a
way of of sort of adding annotations to
the DNA and that seems to be methylation
seems to be quite important it seems to
be important both in the ordinary
operation of organisms and to things
like cancer and and that's a place where
even though you've got this you know
your standard base pair sequence exactly
what that methylation looks like can
affect how things work and so there's a
whole sort of separate world of okay
what um
um what what kind of uh sort of um after
the pure genome what kind of
modifications get made
um I'm not sure I can quite tell you in
an organized way
um there are lots of different things
that are known about how that works one
of the key problems is uh
everybody starts from you know one
fertilized egg cell
it splits in two splits into again
splits into again eventually you get the
hundreds of trillions of cells that make
up each of us
and one thing that happens is those
cells are form different types of
tissues they might form a few hundred
different types of tissues whether
they're hair cells or skin cells or or
lung cells or brain cells or whatever
else they differentiate into different
kinds of tissues and there's a long time
question of how does that
differentiation work how is it the case
that you can go from sort of the the
original stem cell the original sort of
uh Source cell and it differentiates
into this kind that kind that kind and
there are if you look at that sort of
tree of differentiation I think for us
humans it goes about 15 levels deep I
think
um that uh you know if you're trying to
produce a cell of a particular kind
that's sort of 15 choices that you have
to make to get to that particular cell
as opposed to becoming a heart cell or a
or a brain cell or whatever else
um
it used to be thought it was very
difficult to go back to a so-called
pluripotent stem cell a stem cell that
has many possibilities for where it work
where what it will turn into it used to
be thought the only way you could get
those was to go back to fetal tissue
um but turned out that it was figured
out how to kind of take any cell and put
it back into the stem cell state where
it's capable of sort of going anywhere
and the question is well when it goes
when it becomes a particular type of
cell what does it mean to become a
particular type of cell what it means is
in in a particular type of cell the
proteins that are relevant for the
function of that cell are being produced
a lot and the proteins that are relevant
for the function of another cell are not
being produced
um and I think uh I'm not sure what the
latest story on this is I think there's
a bunch of methylation related stuff
that's known about sort of how that
differentiation process happens
um it's been figured out in in fairly
recent years
um but that's sort of one example of a
of a not just the genome but also it's
your same genome but it's a heart cell
um and uh that um uh you know that
that's an example of of one of these
things that sort of not just genomics
um the uh and so
for example there are things that can
affect for example if you have identical
twins
they don't necessarily have everything
the same because they if it was just a
question of their genomes their genomes
are the same but there are aspects of
identical twins that aren't exactly the
same like for example even things like
their fingerprints may have maybe
similar but probably not exactly the
same the shape of their ears the the
kind of the the curling up of the layers
in their brains and so on may be similar
but not the same and part of the reason
for that is that those things like uh
you know fingerprints and so on are the
results of the particular mechanical
folding of tissue when things were
growing and that particular folding of
tissue was not determined by The genome
maybe some Global aspect some coarse
aspects of it were determined by The
genome but the details were not and so
that's something where even with
identical twins they won't end up being
exactly the same and that's what
sometimes called sort of epigenetic
phenomena but they're different levels
of of things that actually go down to
affect things that are sort of direct
modifications The genome versus things
that are much more mechanical like did
it fold this well that way so a few
thoughts about that
um
oh boy all right a few more questions
Ark asks do viruses play an important
role part in evolution I'm not sure we
completely know
um I mean in uh there are so-called
retroviruses that uh go and insert
themselves into one's DNA their viruses
take a a lump of virus DNA and just they
are the analog of what this genetic
editing Gene editing processes they just
go and insert themselves into your DNA
and I kind of wondered I I am because
I've got my genome sequenced first in
2010 I think and now we're 23 13 years
later and it's like if you look at my
genome today and my genome back then if
I got sick with a virus and it happened
to be a retrovirus would there be actual
changes in My DNA well the answer is not
most of it because the virus didn't get
into most of the cells in my body and
most of the cells that did get into my
immune system will have killed off so
there probably isn't a isn't a story
there probably
um but uh you know is that something
that's important in the overall history
of of uh life on Earth undoubtedly yes
undoubtedly it's important because among
other things viruses have much more
rapid uh DNA you know much more rapid
genomic change than typical organisms
they have much shorter uh kind of um
replication times they have much less
DNA so they don't have doesn't take as
long to replicate that
um and uh so that that um you know
they're probably a a fast running place
where changes can be made and if they
can insert themselves or even uh
possibly their interaction with the
defining the environment the fitness I
mean it could be the case you know some
virus comes in and it evolved in a
particular way and it wipes out some
part of the population
that would otherwise have been
considered quite fit and quite able to
produce lots of lots of uh descendants
and and so that's another mechanism well
by which one can expect that sort of the
evolution of viruses is correlated with
the evolution of other other organisms
um
boy gal asks why is it the mammals like
whales and dolphins made their way back
to the ocean uh to evolve as as
creatures living in the sea rather than
staying on land I don't know that
history in detail
um I know that um uh
you know
evolution is a very gradual process and
when things have to happen suddenly
Evolution isn't really able to do them
so for example if you look at the first
fish in when was it maybe
Carboniferous period or something when
no it's earlier than that I think when
when there were first sort of creatures
on the land
um you know it's the fins were like okay
you can kind of push yourself on the on
the beach with your fins and then oh no
you know now their legs and now you can
walk on the um uh on the land
and I think uh if you're
hey um you know if you look at the
structure of the fins in in something
like uh you know whale dolphin whatever
else that bone structure is very similar
to the bone structure of our hands and
feet
um they just have you know they're
bigger and so at least whales are and so
they have more just as we have how many
segments is it like three segments in
our fingers
um there their finger analogs have like
I don't know 15 segments or something
but they still have the same basic bone
structure and it's again it's a it's
this terrible feature or or good feature
I don't know how you think about it a
biological evolution that there are
there are very few new ideas so it's
like we've got the idea of a hand we've
got this idea of a thing that is sort of
a uh you know a flat modifiable thing
okay let's use it as a flipper let's use
it as a hand and you know for us in in
when when our hands grow they actually
start as was webbing between the fingers
and the cells that form that webbing die
off before before we're born and that's
how we end up with these separated
fingers but you know kind of the idea of
can you make a web thing that has the
same bone structure well yes you can now
why those organisms uh sort of went back
in the ocean from the land I don't know
um usually these these things you can
kind of tell a story in retrospect for
why something happened but it may not be
quotes really why it happened I mean for
all one knows you know things got cold
on the land and so then and it was
warmer in the ocean I don't know
um or the uh the it became worthwhile to
be bigger and bigger and bigger and by
the time you was that big it was hard to
walk around on the land all sorts of
different things like that I don't know
um and and there may be no
there may be no good answer other than a
an answer in retrospect where you're
kind of telling a story that's just
about what actually happened and you're
not really explaining quotes why that
happened
um
I don't know what this means I'm I'm the
the uh
okay maybe one last
question here from from William
uh
another biology question but a little
bit different than we've been talking
about
how does the brain distinguish signals
coming from different senses what's the
difference between signals coming from
the eye versus the ear is everything
ultimately an electrical signal is it
not a difference in it's a difference in
degree instead of in kind you know in a
sense the answer that is very very
simple you know we have a bundle of
nerves that go our optic nerve that goes
from our eyes to the visual cortex to
the back of our brains we have a bundle
of nerves that come from our cochlear
and our ears to the auditory Center in
our brains and in a sense they're just
different wires we know that it's Vision
because it's coming down the vision
wires so to speak to that part of the
brain we know it's sound because it's
coming down those wires in effect
the signals are very similar I mean I
think in the uh you know you might have
thought oh sound will be it'll record
just like on a computer it'll have
direct data on you know the the eardrum
was pushed in out in out at the speed no
that's not actually how things are
encoded what's done is the the
frequencies are separated by the by uh
you know hair cells at different places
in the cochlea move at different but
when when the sound has different
frequency components and by the time
it's being transmitted to the brain it's
really oh in this sound there was this
intensity at this frequency it's very
very similar to the way when we're
looking in in Vision we're saying oh
this photocell photoreceptor on our
retina was excited by these photons
coming from this angle it's there's
something going on to the left there
it's very similar to there's something
going on at a high frequency there but
in the end and all of these signals are
just electrical signals and nerve cells
in these chunks of nerves that come from
our different sensory organs and I don't
think there's a significant difference
in what you see I mean in other words
the a nerve cell that's been excited
it's kind of like producing electrical
signals
usually about a thousandth of a second
apart
um and if it hasn't been excited it's
just hanging out and occasionally making
a little dip just for fun
um and uh no doubt it isn't just for fun
no doubt it has some uh biological
origin or some electrochemical origin
but in any case the the thing that um uh
you know the way we know what sentence
coming from is literally what wire it
came down and the same is true for for
touch for example you know we're
literally mapping you know when when you
touch your finger there's a particular
nerve endings in your finger and there's
a particular nerve fiber that will go
and it will be that there won't be a
single fiber it has repeatas in
different places is in as it goes up
towards your brain through your spinal
cord into your brain and it's literally
that wire got connected to some
particular place in your brain
um and that's how you know that it comes
from that source and not another
now it'll be very interesting if we
manage to make direct neural connections
of things that one will end up being
able to remap all that stuff and um uh
it'll be very bizarre and I don't know
how quickly one will learn I have a
feeling when we'll learn rather quickly
oh this is the Sensation that comes with
uh the thing is trying to tell one that
the answer is seven or something
um and but I but I don't know quite what
that will be like
um and El Conway was asking do we need a
lot more wires for vision compared to
listening yeah the optic nerve has about
10 million fibers the auditory nerve has
about 50 000 fibers so there's a lot
more data coming from uh vision is uh um
uh what is that factor
um
it's um a factor of 200 difference so
there's the and in a sense that's
reflected in computers when we say well
44 kilohertz is
um you know let's say 44 let's say
um 100 kilobits per second let's say 100
000 bits per second is kind of what we
need for a good audio uh good computer
audio but if we want good computer video
we'll need
um uh let's see that will need to be at
least um
uh 100 million bits per second or more
it's actually pretty much now they think
about it it's pretty much in exactly the
ratio of the number of nerve fibers that
we have going from our ears to our
brains and our eyes to our brains so so
yes that that's um it uh that's that's
how it works it's very direct it's very
um in a sense very straightforward
um
okay I probably uh
um okay William is asking I can't resist
this question what are the implications
regarding the ability for the brain to
acquire another sense unlike the five
senses we already have
you know different organisms have
different funky senses you know bats use
echolocation they make ultrasonic pulses
where they which bounce off things and
that's how they know when those pulses
come back that's how they know how far
away things are and uh I don't know the
what is it the star mole I think is
famous for having I don't think it has
eyes but I think it has some electrical
sensors that tell it sort of where
things are and um there are there are
all kinds of different sensors that
different organisms have I think snakes
have heat sensors
um I think uh uh well pigeons for
example probably have magnetic field
sensors in their brains maybe we have
magnetic field sensors in our brains we
don't know for sure
um but there are different types of of
of sensing devices that exist in
different organisms and the question is
you know different organisms take their
sensory data more or less seriously like
dogs for example have huge emphasis some
smell as a sensory as a sense whereas we
don't and uh I think they smell as big
you know vision is not so big for dogs
vision is big for cats you know these
kinds of things
um it's uh uh and you can kind of see
that reflected in the number of nerve
fibers that come from those different uh
sensory organs into brains
um so
the question is if we were to have if we
were to introduce completely new senses
well in effect we we have that all the
time because any kind of measuring
device is kind of giving us maybe maybe
our readout is because we can see it you
know the meter in our eyes or maybe we
have something that's you know uh
clicking in our ear or something like
this
um you know that's the way that we have
extended our sensory domain is with all
sorts of measuring devices now when one
can do that not through the medium of
some existing uh sort of sense like
Vision or or or sound but one can do it
directly into the brain what's that
going to feel like
my guess is
well I don't know my guess is not going
to feel like much I don't think it's
going to be that different I think
people
you know it's it's like people who
practice various kinds of things like uh
various kinds of meditation and things
like that think that they can start sort
of sensing things with their brains that
most people don't sense like blood
pressure things like that which most
people are just not the only way you can
know your blood pressure is by measuring
it with a blood pressure cuff but you
know the people who who say well I can
learn to to to get that I think actually
sometimes even without something as
fancy as that you can learn some kinds
of things because you can say I'm going
to have the sensor that shows me
something about
um I think oh gosh I think maybe leaving
the blood pressure you can do this but
if you if you have something although
it's hard to measure that continuously
so maybe maybe other things but you know
you can say I'm trying to learn how to
sense this aspect to myself well if I
can get this display that shows me this
aspect of myself
um the uh you know can you can you kind
of learn
what can you correlate what you can see
on the display with how you feel
um and uh then
um you know that that's a that's a way
in which you can kind of uh you can
learn by correlating what you see on the
display with how it feels in your brain
and you can end up uh sensing some other
thing like like I don't know sensing
glucose level then your blood is one
thing that um uh you know potentially
you can learn and potentially now that
there are continuous glucose monitors
um you could potentially learn oh you
know this feels like uh you know high
glucose level or whatever you know I
just ate something I can I can feel the
glucose Peak from eating that potato or
whatever else it is
um and uh uh you know which which people
usually cannot but but um something you
can potentially learn if you have that
feedback from uh from an external source
all right we should probably wrap up uh
here for today but um a very genomic day
and biological day today
um and thank you for asking different
different kinds of questions and um uh I
look forward to um
uh to doing this again another day
thanks very much and bye for now